AT 9:00 A.M. AND NOON ON
WEEKDAYS.
TUCKER CARLSON IS UP NEXT
>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
THE SEPARATION OF CHILDREN OF
THE BORDER HAS SINCE, IT CEASED
TO BE A NEWS STORY, IT NOW SEEMS
TO BE A COMPETITION TO SEE WHO
CAN REACH GREATER HEIGHTS OF
RHETORICAL SUCCESS AND
SELF-RIGHTEOUS POSTURING.
NANCY PELOSI AND EVEN
HILLARY CLINTON TOOK AN EARLY
LEAD IN THE CONTEST BY BYPASSING
PUBLIC POLICY QUESTIONS ENTIRELY
AND MOVING STRAIGHT TO THEOLOGY.
>> THE HYPOCRISY OF ALL PEOPLE
IN OUR COUNTRY NOT TO CLAMBER
FOR WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING TO END.
THOSE WHO JUSTIFY CENTRAL TENET
OF CHRISTIANITY.
JESUS SAID SUFFER THE LITTLE
CHILDREN ONTO ME.
HE DID NOT SAY LOVE THE CHILDREN
SUFFER.
>> Sandra: 'S OF THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT THE THIRD
TERM POST-VIABILITY ABORTION FOR
PURPOSES OF SELECTION ARE NOW
LECTURING YOU ABOUT GOD AND SIN
AND THE HOLINESS OF
CHILDREN.
FEEL CHASTENED?
BUT WAIT, THERE IS MORE.
ON FACEBOOK, BEN SASSE CALLED
THE ADMINISTRATION'S POLICY
WICKED AS AN IMMORAL AND
DEVILISH.
FIRST LADY LAURA BUSH LIKENED IT
TO THE INTERNAL AND MICHAEL
HAYDEN WENT ALL THE WAY.
HE PRINTED OUT A PICTURE OF
AUSCHWITZ DEATH CAMP AND
COMPARED THAT TO THE.
AFTER SOBERING UP, HE WALKED TO
THAT BACK A LITTLE BIT ON
TELEVISION, BUT NOT MUCH.
>> I KNOW WE ARE NOT, GERMANY.
BUT THERE'S A COMMONALITY THERE.
A MORE CIVILIZED PEOPLE YOU
CANNOT FIND.
SO I WAS TRYING TO POINT OUT, WE
NEED TO BE CAREFUL NOT TO MOVE
IN THAT DIRECTION.
>> Tucker: WE COULD GO ON,
THERE WAS SO MUCH MORE JUST LIKE
THAT.
THE RICH AND POWERFUL REMINDING
YOU JUST HOW VIRTUOUS THEY ARE.
DO YOU THINK ANY OF THESE PEOPLE
REALLY CARE ABOUT FAMILY
SEPARATION?
IF THEY DID, THEY WOULD BE
WORRIED ABOUT THE COLLAPSE OF
THE AMERICAN FAMILY WHICH IS
MEASURABLE AND REAL CAMP BUT
THEY ARE NOT WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
THEY WILL NOT COLLAPSE BECAUSE
STRONG FAMILIES ARE AN
IMPEDIMENTS TO THEIR POLITICAL
POWER AND THAT'S WHY THEY ARE
ALWAYS LECTURING YOU ABOUT THE
PATRIARCHY AND THE EVIL OF THE
AMERICAN FAMILY.
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
CHILDREN ARE GROWING UP WITH ONE
PARENT AT HOME.
MANY OF THOSE KIDS BY THE WAY
HAVE A PARENT BEHIND BARS.
NOT JUST ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO
ARE SEPARATED FROM THEIR
CHILDREN, BUT THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS IN PRISON HAVE
MINOR KIDS THAT THEY HAVE LEFT
BEHIND.
THEY'VE BEEN SEPARATED BECAUSE
THEY HAVE COMMITTED A CRIME.
SO IN A WAY THESE KIDS ARE JUST
LIKE THE KIDS ON TELEVISION
TODAY BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS THEY
ARE AMERICANS, SO NOBODY IS
SPENDING 35 GRAND PER YEAR
APIECE TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE
OKAY.
POLITICIANS AND CABLE NEWS
ANCHORS DON'T VISIT THE FOSTER
HOMES TO HIGHLIGHT THEIR PLATE,
THEY ARE IGNORED.
THEY CARE FAR MORE ABOUT
FOREIGNERS THAN THEIR OWN
PEOPLE.
THE OTHER THING YOU MAY HAVE
NOTICED IS THEY ARE NOT
ESPECIALLY INTERESTED IN
SOLUTIONS TO ANYTHING.
THEY ARE GREAT AT YELLING AND
PREENING BUT NOT SO MUCH AT
FIXING.
WE COULD EVEN BUILD MORE HOUSING
FACILITIES TO ALLOW FAMILIES TO
STAY TOGETHER WHILE THEY ARE
ASYLUM CLAIMS ARE PROCESSED.
THE LEFT IS NOT INTERESTED IN
ANY OF THAT, THEIR ONLY SOLUTION
IS IMMEDIATE AMNESTY FOR ANYONE
THAT CROSSES OUR BORDERS WITH A
MINOR IN TOTAL.
AT THE SAME AS NO BORDERS AT
ALL.
THAT'S A POWERFUL INCENTIVE FOR
CHILD SMUGGLING.
LOTS OF PEOPLE YELLING AT YOU ON
TV DON'T EVEN HAVE CHILDREN SO
DON'T FOR A SECOND LET THEM TAKE
THE MORAL HIGH GROUND.
THEIR GOAL IS TO CHANGE YOUR
COUNTRY FOREVER AND THEY ARE
SUCCEEDING BY THE WAY.
SINCE 2014, TO NAME ONE EXAMPLE,
AT LEAST HALF A MILLION CENTRAL
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN RELEASED
INSIDE OF OUR BORDERS.
DID ANYONE VOTE FOR THAT?
THE KIDS ON OUR -- IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS LOOK LIKE THEY DID
IN 1960.
THERE IS NO COST TO THEM.